søren kierkegaard
was a brilliant gloomy anxiety written
often hilarious Danish 19th century
philosopher the author of 22 books of
which 3 continued to make his name he
was born in an immensely wealthy family
in Copenhagen in 1813 the youngest of
seven children death was around him
constantly from a young age and was to
obsess him throughout his career it is
in a sense his only theme not only was
he extremely physically frail by the
time he was twenty-two all his siblings
had died except for he and a brother it
drove him to furious production of books
of the 15 years on a single day in 1843
he published no less than three works he
wasn't writing for the money he was
working to save himself and he thought
humanity as it happened he made it to
the age of 42 then died of an
excruciatingly spinal disease in
either/or and fear and trembling what
kick yard wants us to do above all is
wake up and give up our cozy sentimental
illusions he systematically attacks the
pillars of modern life our faith in
family our trust in work our attachment
to love and our general sense that life
has purpose and meaning his enemies with
a smug in all their guises particularly
the prosperous Danish ought bourgeoisie
and the members of the established
Danish Church he tells us as I grew up I
opened my eyes and saw the real world
and I began to laugh and I haven't
stopped since I saw that the meaning of
life was to get a livelihood that the
goal of life was to be a high court
judge that the brightest joy of love was
to marry a well-off girl that wisdom was
what the majority said it was that
passion was to give a speech that
courage was to risk being fined $10 that
cordiality was to say you're welcome
after a meal and that the fear of God
was to go to communion once a year
that's what I saw and I laughed kick
guard was especially caustic about the
nineteenth-century understanding of love
and the new ideology of passionate
marriage which aimed to unite desire
with prudence and suggested that one
could enjoy all the thrills of a love
affair
and at the same time all the stability
of a long-term relationship but kick
guard mocked the notion the one could
ever fuse romantic love with marriage
that one could have passion and sex and
at the same time children's stability
and routine he respected both he just
couldn't believe that you could have
them both at the same time in a cozy
marriage sanctified by the state and the
neighbors his belief arose out of his
own tortured love life he fell in love
with a beautiful precocious and talented
eighteen-year-old girl called Regina
Olsen only then to break off the
engagement as he realized that a try and
live with her forever would also mean
killing the love that had drawn him to
her everywhere he turned Kierkegaard saw
intolerable incompatibilities and
impossible choices it led him to one
memorable explosion in either or Mary
and you will regret it don't marry you
will also regret it marry or don't marry
you will regret it either way laugh at
the world's foolishness you will regret
it
weep over it you'll regret that to hang
yourself you'll regret it don't hang
yourself and you'll regret that -
whether you hang yourself or don't hang
yourself you will regret both this
gentleman is the essence of all
philosophy the mention of laughter is
not a coincidence Keter Kierkegaard's
philosophy is that the only intelligent
tactical response to life's horror is to
laugh defiantly at it rarely as a
philosopher taken humor as seriously
kick a guard is often described as the
founder of the philosophical movement
known as existentialism because in him
we find all the themes that would so
interest later thinkers like sarch
Camus and Heidegger the book that
fascinated the existentialist was kick
guards the concept of anxiety published
in 1844 in which he emphasized a new
word honest or angst as we know it in
English a condition where we understand
how many choices we face and how little
understanding we can ever have of how to
exercise these choices wisely ask a
keyguard wrote life can only be
understood backwards but must be lived
forwards a constant angst means that
unhappiness is more or less written into
the script of life as he wrote anyone
who has given the matter any serious
thought will know that I'm right when I
say it's not possible for anyone to be
absolutely and in every conceivable way
completely content not even for a single
half-hour of his life no one has come
into the world without crying no one
asks when you want to enter the world no
one asks when you want to leave how
empty and meaningless life is we bury a
person throw three shovels of Earth over
him drive out in a coach drive back in a
coach and console ourselves that we
still have life enough left to live but
really how long is threescore and ten
why not just get it over with
straightaway for kick guard there was
however one answer that he put forward
evermore stridently in his later works
Jesus Christ
kicki guard loathed the christianity of
the established danish church but he
adored the simple truths of the gospels
that his father had taught him as a boy
for him christianity was a religion of
extreme surrender to a theology of
almost peasant like simplicity one was
to be ready to die for Christ to give up
all attachment to worldly things and to
love all humans like one's siblings
Kierkegaard wasn't interested in
justifying his attachment to
Christianity through rational means
instead he recommended a dramatic and
now famous leap of faith where anyone
wouldn't apply one's puny mind to
attempting to prove the existence of God
one would merely switch off one's faulty
rational faculties and jump into the
idea of God as the total solution as he
put it to have faith is to lose your
mind and to win God like Marxist
communism keke guards solutions to the
problems of being human are far less
convincing and interesting than the
diagnosis of our ills few of us now make
that leap but keiki God deserves our
attention for the beautifully bitter
caustic look he cast on the human
condition he's one of the few
philosophers one can turn to when the
world has badly let us down and we're in
need of a friend who can fully
understand the dark places we're in once
the sentimental illusions that normally
keep us going fall away
you